en el primer vídeo de evolución dibuje
algo a lo que llamé simio y luego le
dibuje cola y lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es aclarar que eso estaba
completamente mal los simios no tienen
cola déjame notarlo los sí
ellos
no tienen cola sí
y de hecho es uno de los rasgos
característicos de los simios obviamente
también hay otros primates que no tienen
cola pero los simios definitivamente no
tienen cola y sólo para aclarar existen
dos familias de simios y sus nombres
comunes son los y los batidos osim y los
menores y los homínidos o grandes simios
y los y los batidos incluyen a los
gibones como aquí y estos de aquí son y
los batidos o simios menores y los
batidos justo como estos mientras que
los homínidos incluyen a los chimpancés
a los gorilas y a mí a los seres humanos
así que bueno estos de aquí estos de
aquí son homínidos déjame ponerlo
nidos o grandes simios homínidos y bueno
claramente este homínido que tenemos
aquí es decir yo
salman khan no tenía mucho sentido de la
moda en 1994 y le hace falta un buen
corte de pelo